Oh
that's why we see
we feel that the students here at
carnegie mellon have a very special
relationship with the steelers and we
want to support them in every way we can
especially with our music and our voices
we're enthusiastic about the team we're
enthusiastic about pittsburgh we have
students from all over the country and
the world that come here and they all
eventually fall into the steeler trance
and become supportive of this great team
the toreador song from carmen is a
fighting song it brings forth the
masculinity of s camille going into the
bullring to fight the bull and we just
feel that it's a perfect tune to
substitute steeler words for B's A's
words in the toreador song